in a time where everyone is staying home
and avoiding travel
it's not surprising to see airline and
hotel companies post massive losses
this was the same case with airbus at
the start of the pandemic
we saw quarterly losses ranging between
500 million dollars
and 1.5 billion dollars right off the
bat
these losses were much less than their
main competitor boeing
who was burning three to four billion
dollars every quarter
what's even more surprising though is
that airbus was not only able to reduce
their losses
but even become profitable in the last
quarter of 2020
pulling in 1.7 billion dollars meanwhile
boeing just posted their worst quarter
in 15 years
losing 8.4 billion dollars in a single
quarter
so how did airbus recover so quickly
from the pandemic
unlike boeing one of the key advantages
airbus has over boeing
is the airbus a320 the airbus a320
versus the boeing 737 has been one of
the closest battles
over the past few decades as of november
total orders of all boeing 737 models
reached 15
136 aircrafts while total orders of all
a320 models stood at 15
193 aircrafts the a320 did slightly have
a lead over the boeing 737
but you wouldn't quite say that either
company was really winning
until you considered one crucial factor
the first boeing 737 flew in april
of 1967 while the first airbus a320
didn't fly till february of 1987.
this means that airbus was able to catch
up to boeing despite their 20-year head
start
so it's no question that a320s have been
selling extremely well
and this has really helped airbus
recover during the pandemic
as airline travel starts up again the
first routes that are making a return
are of course domestic routes traveling
internationally has more bars
and risks today than ever before so
people as well as businesses are
choosing to stick to domestic travel
as much as possible additionally many
airlines are choosing to use narrow body
jets
even on medium to long-haul routes as
well
when demand for these longer routes is
less than half of the usual levels
it makes no sense to continue burning
money on larger jets
this shift in demand has led to narrow
body airplane demand performing much
better than wide body airplane demand
and as we previously discussed within
the narrow body airplane market
it does seem like airlines before the
a320 over the 737.
this advantage for airbus has only been
accelerated forward
by boeing's blunder with the 737 max
after two fatal 737 max accidents in
the boeing 737 max was grounded around
the world for nearly two years
in december of 2020 the faa did approve
the 737 max for flight
but it's going to take boeing quite a
while to become competitive against the
a320
once again many airline passengers were
spooked by the 737 max incident
and they aren't willing to find a 737
max until they've seen years of
reliability in the market
given that airline passengers are then
customers of aircrafts
will likely see airlines approach the
737 max with caution
which just further helped the a320 aside
from a massive advantage in the narrow
body airplane market
airbus happened to use a perfect time to
stop a380 production
the a380 was a super ambitious double
decker plane meant to compete against
the boeing 747
the large interior space allowed for
super luxurious business
and first class cabins and even the
economy seating was some of the best
out there the a380 also had no major
safety
or reliability errors despite its
massive size
pilots loved it passengers loved it and
engineers loved it
most airlines however did not love it
the problem with the a380 was simply
that it didn't make economical
or logistical sense for airlines most
airports could not handle the a380
and new jet ways and terminals had to be
built specifically for the aircraft
also most routes did not need that much
passenger capacity
to begin with for the routes that could
support that many passengers
it often made more sense to split the
passengers into two smaller aircrafts
this way passengers had more options in
terms of departure time and airlines
could more easily scale up or scale down
with demand
not to mention it airlines could save
significant amounts of money by flying
two smaller aircrafts that are more fuel
efficient
so though the a380 was an engineering
masterpiece and the passenger favorite
demand for the aircraft was not as much
as airbus initially anticipated
fortunately for airbus though they
decided to stop production
at precisely the right time in february
of 2019
airbus announced that they would stop
production of the a380
though this was a sad event this allowed
airbus to smoothly scale out of
production throughout the pandemic
at the time of the announcement airbus
only had 17 a380 orders left
three were going to all nip and airways
and the rest were going to emirates
as of december 2020 airbus finished
delivering all three a380s to all nippon
airways
and they just have 5 more to deliver to
emirates
meanwhile boeing 747 orders have been
dwindling as well
for the same reasons since 2016 747
production has slowed to just six units
per day
and boeing has lost an average of 40
million dollars on each unit
at that rate boeing was losing about a
quarter billion dollars every year by
just keeping the 747 around
despite this boeing refused to halt 747
production
until after the pandemic began and the
company was significantly
in the red so at this point airbus had
played the narrow body and the super
jumbo jet category is better than boeing
the only category left is wide body jets
and
in this market the boeing 787 dreamliner
is no doubt
the airline favorite the 787 is by far
the most fuel-efficient plane on the
market not only does the 787 save on
fuel costs
but it is generally quite a bit cheaper
than its a350 counterparts
take the 787-10 and the a350-1000 for
instance
the 787-10 cost 325.8 million dollars
while the a350-1000 costs 366.5 million
dollars
this means that airlines can save 40
million dollars by opting for the 787
over the a350 and that's not even taking
into account bulk order discounts
which will likely only make the
disparity even larger
this disparity is super clear when you
take a look at orders for either
aircraft
as of august 2019 boeing had a total of
1464787 orders
out of which 882 had already been
delivered
airbus on the other hand only had a
total of 913 a350 orders out of which
only 300 were delivered
clearly this was a category that airbus
was significantly lagging behind in
but ironically this worked out perfectly
for airbus
as we previously discussed international
travel demand has fallen off a cliff
since the start of the pandemic
and this is where 787s triple 7s and
a350s are primarily used
given that 737 maxes were grounded
triple 7s and 787s were crucial to
boeing's business
but unfortunately the wide-body market
was severely impacted by the pandemic
and as for airbus given that customers
far prefer the 787
airbus was never that dependent on the
a350 to begin with
so in terms of the passenger airline
business airbus was simply
at the right place at the right time and
boeing was not
boeing couldn't have chosen a worse time
to fill with a narrow body jet
and airbus couldn't have chosen a better
time to step away from super jumbo jets
couple this with a smaller dependency on
the wide-body market
and it's not hard to see why airbus
weathered a downturn
quite well but all of that is just
what's apparent
on the surface those points are
absolutely valid
and played a large role in either
company's outcome however
there are many more factors that
influence the outcome from the
background
such as poor leadership over the past 20
years boeing's leadership has become
more
and more focused on their stock price as
opposed to their core business
this has led them to focus on numbers
and statistics instead of meeting the
needs of their customers
for instance there have been countless
stories online about how leadership at
boeing
pressured employees to rush through
training and rush through safety checks
and rush through problems in general
this was in an effort to push out as
many aircrafts as possible
and bolster their stock price as much as
they could over the short term the
detriments of this flawed approach
aren't visible but with time we'll see
bigger
and bigger mistakes and the 737 max was
simply one example of that
if boeing's leadership wasn't so
short-sighted they likely would have
caught the issues with the 737 max
during inspection and they wouldn't have
had to deal with such a massive fiasco
as for airbus leadership they're not
perfect by any means either
at the end of 2019 airbus had just gone
through a three-year bribery
investigation
and airbus would end up settling with a
4 billion fine
fun fact this was actually the largest
bribery settlement amount
in history so clearly airbus is by no
means a saint
but over the past 20 years their
leadership hasn't been nearly as focused
on share price
as boeing has this is likely because
airbus isn't as mature of a company
as boeing even today airbus is worth
about 98 billion dollars
and boeing is worth 145 billion dollars
so
airbus has historically had more room to
grow within their core business
itself meanwhile boeing has had to get
more creative to continue
indefinite stock growth something else
to consider is that boeing space
defense and securities business is much
larger than that of airbus
boeing space defense and securities
business generates about 26 billion
every year while airbus space and
defense business only generates 10
billion
per year so airbus is likely more
focused than boeing on their commercial
customers
as they have less diversification
anyways
in the end the main reasons airbus was
able to recover so quickly from the
pandemic
is that their leadership has been more
focused on their customers than boeing
and their position within the market
simply held it better than that
of boeing why do you guys think airbus
was able to turn around
so fast comment that down below also
drop a like if you guys thought this
video explained the situations of either
company well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one